hi I'm Susie Kanda producer on resident
evil village and I'm Pete Fabiana also
produced here on resonable village we
hope you all had a chance to check out
and enjoy our trailer some of you are
probably wondering why we didn't just
call the game Resident Evil 8 well it's
still the 8th in the series and we're
treating it as such you can even see the
Roman numeral eight in the game logo so
it's Resident Evil 8 just not in name
yeah I like to play on the design and
the simplicity in the name but we'll
touch more on that a little later
now why don't we just jump in and let
viewers know a little bit more about the
game itself
first off Resident Evil villager will be
available on PlayStation 5 Xbox series X
and Steam right and in line with
previous Resident Evil titles we're
using re engine that engine brought
Resident Evil 7 biohazard resin evil -
Devil May Cry 5 and most recently
resonable 3 - life we were able to take
all that we learn from those titles
along with our internal development
efforts and optimize the latest version
of the engine for the next generation of
consoles with a combined power of
next-gen and re engine we can take our
developers vision to new heights
once again we're planning a fresh take
on survival horror this time I think
antioxidative
realistic graphics and immersive audio
coupled with no load times really draw
you into the world we've created for
Resident Evil Village
speaking of which the game takes place a
few years after the events of Resident
Evil 7 biohazard right and it follows
the story of protagonist Ethan winters
Ethan's gone back to living an ordinary
life but of course it wouldn't be a
proper story without a new challenge to
overcome Chris Redfield a decorated hero
fighting against bioterrorism makes his
return but not in the way you'd think
he's the reason
Ethan's life gets turned upside down
let's take a look at some key art you
can see a Chris looking dark and far
more brooding than in aerial Resident
Evil appearances the last thing worth
mentioning in terms of characters here
is the village itself it plays such a
crucial role as the backdrop and setting
of the game that we consider it very
much its own character as well right
shifting gears let's talk a bit about
the game's design you'll notice the
familiar first-person perspective from
Resident Evil 7 biohazard it really
helps bring players into the world makes
them feel like they're Ethan with the
same sense of heightened tension and
fear
here's a quick look of the game running
an engine the team is working really
hard to create a great experience you
can really see the details even close up
let's take a look at the inventory for
players familiar with Resident Evil 7
biohazard or the recent versions of
Resident Evil 2 & 3 you'll be right at
home we hope you enjoyed this additional
look into Resident Evil Village oh and
here's one more piece of cure you might
want to pay extra close attention to
this one there's love that's being shown
in it so much so that we debated whether
or not to actually put it in an ounce
trader take a look and let your
imagination run wild we are aiming to
have more to show you towards the end of
summer so until next time
[Music]
you